-Our first guest tonight is an
Academy Award-Winning actress
you know from her work
in films such as
"Vicky Cristina Barcelona,"
"Volver," and "Nine."
She's received her fourth Oscar
nomination for her performance
in "Parallel Mothers,"
which is in theaters
and On Demand now.
Let's take a look.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Please welcome to the show,
Penelope Cruz, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, Penelope. Welcome.
-Hi.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
It's so lovely to see you.
-Great to see you, too.
Thank you so much.
-So, this is so exciting.
Not only is it your fourth
Oscar nomination,
but your husband, Javier Bardem,
also got nominated for an Oscar.
I'm wondering, on the day,
were your children --
how do they react to the news
that both of their parents
are Oscar-nominated?
-Well, they found out later,
because when we saw them,
they -- when we saw it live,
it was 2:30 P.M. here
and they were in the school.
And then when we told them
later, the only question
that my daughter asked me
was if there was going
to be any cake to celebrate.
[ Laughter ]
That was the only comment,
and I think that's a very
healthy reaction.
[ Laughter ]
-How long -- how long
was the gap between
when one of you found out
you were nominated
and the other one
found out they were nominated?
-It was, like,
probably like five minutes.
I mean, you know, a huge
surprise to hear one name,
then to hear the other one, too,
is really,
really something to celebrate.
A part of me still
doesn't believe it.
-This is also --
must be extra special.
This is your seventh film
with Pedro Almodovar,
who you first worked with when
you were a teenager, correct?
-Yeah. I met him
when I was 18 or 19.
He called me when he saw
my first two movies.
And when he called me,
I thought it was a joke,
because it was my dream
in my childhood
and my teenager years
to meet him,
to thank him for all the work
that he did
and maybe one day
to work with him.
So, yeah, when he called me,
it was like an instant
connection.
We felt like already
we knew each other,
and we decided to keep
working together,
and we've done seven movies
together.
I hope many more.
-And this is a story,
"Parallel" -- "Parallel Mothers"
is based on a story that he told
you about decades ago, correct?
-Yeah, he told me the first time
maybe like 20 years ago,
when we were doing press
for "All About My Mother,"
and then he never mentioned the
story again for so many years
And in the middle of the first
lockdown -- COVID lockdown --
he called me and he said,
"I'm writing this for you,
and this is the story."
And I told him
that I remembered every detail
because he shared with me
so long before.
-And your first film with him,
is it true that you did a scene
with your future mother-in-law?
Yes, yes, with Pilar Bardem.
It was kind of a rehearsal
of real life.
I mean, thank God I didn't have
to give birth in a bus.
Like, that's what happened
with my character in the film.
But, yeah, yeah, destiny had
like a lot of plans for us.
It was a my first movie
with Pedro,
and it was the opening
of the film.
It was like only 10 minutes
of the film,
and I was giving birth in a bus
for those 10 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
-Pedro really likes using you
as a mother character.
I think that that's safe to say.
-Yes, he always saw my very
strong maternal instincts.
-Yes.
-And all the movies
that I've done with him,
I was either pregnant
or I was a mother,
except for one movie
called "Broken Embraces."
All the other films,
he has really taken
advantage of that
maternal instinct.
-And now, your mother
was a hairdresser.
And I'm wondering, did you ever
pick up any of those skills?
Did they come in handy
during this pandemic,
when none of us could go
get our hair done?
-Well, that's funny
that you say that,
because I'm always looking
for victims, you know?
Like, people that let me cut
their hair or do waxing
or all the things that I learned
there with my mother,
but I always try
to cut people's hair, always.
And, yeah, it's true
that during those times,
I cut everybody's hair,
so I was happy about that.
And a lot of friends of mine,
like my friend Salma Hayek,
she has trusted me doing
her hair and makeup,
waxing, all kinds of things,
so...
-Well, you must be good at it.
Has anyone ever -- I mean,
even though it's a free haircut,
has anyone ever demanded
their money back?
-No, they haven't.
They haven't complained.
I mean, you can try once.
If you want,
you're more than welcome.
-Sign me up.
-[Indistinct]
-I gave Javier a hard time
the last time he was here.
I didn't really give him
a hard time.
I said one of my favorite
haircuts in any movie
is his in "The Counselor."
And I asked him what you felt
about it when he had
this hairstyle.
Will you tell us what your take
was when you saw?
[ Laughter ]
-I was kind of used to it
already,
because I've seen things
like, uh,
"No Country for Old Men," like,
you know...
-Yeah.
I guess that --
"No Country" might be
the least-sexy haircut
in any film, ever.
-Yeah, but he was so great
in the film,
and, yeah, that was a really
strange character
to the one in "The Counselor,"
but he was great also.
He's always so good.
He's such a great actor.
-You were both great
in that film.
I want to ask, you know,
in these final days,
is it a stressful time,
or is it just exciting
to be nominated for an Oscar?
-It's just exciting,
and it just makes me think about
all the people
that have been there,
you know,
from the beginning.
Obviously, about Pedro,
because he has trusted me
so much from day one,
and he gives me
all these incredible characters.
When I hear my name in a
nomination like this,
and it's the first time
I think --
I feel very grateful
for my peers,
my colleagues, the people
that are voting for me,
and for all the people
that keep giving me, you know,
great characters and good
films and the opportunity
to make a living out of this
profession, out of this job.
It was my dream all my life,
growing up, to be an actor,
and when I said it
to my parents,
it sounded like I wanted
to go to the moon
because we didn't know anybody
in our neighborhood
or family or friends,
anybody that could make
a living out of anything
related to the arts.
So it just makes me think
of all of them.
Also about my parents,
that they didn't laugh at me
when I said to them,
"I want to be an actress."
So, yeah, I feel very, very
grateful, very grateful.
-You're very lucky
to have that support,
and it really is
a beautiful film.
I really want everybody
to see it.
I don't want to give anything
away talking about it,
because it is really
something to see.
It's well-earned.
Congratulations, and thanks
so much for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-Penelope Cruz, everybody.
"Parallel Mothers" is in
theaters and On Demand now.